un descubrimiento que podría reescribir
la historia un informe publicado en la
revista science advanced sugiere que el
homo sapiens existió en europa varios
miles de años antes de lo pensado lo que
significa que podría haber coexistido
con los neandertales después este
hallazgo muestra que había humanos
modernos allí hace unos 54 mil años
mucho antes de lo que pensábamos y lo
interesante es que los neandertales
volvieron después un equipo de
arqueólogos dirigido por el profesor
ludovic sleimán de la universidad de
toulouse descubrió el diente de un niño
y herramientas de piedra en crowd
mandrin una cueva del sur de francia las
herramientas fueron hechas con puntas
afiladas un diseño que no se atribuye a
los neandertales sino a la industria
neroniana un único diente que presentaba
características de un humano moderno es
ahora la evidencia más antigua de la
especie en europa
este hallazgo es probablemente el
primero de muchos vamos a obtener mucha
más información sobre la interacción de
los últimos neandertales y los primeros
humanos modernos y vendrán más
descubrimientos de fósiles
y también particularmente importante
pruebas de adn de algunos de estos
fósiles bastante fragmentarios el
descubrimiento de la corta estancia del
homo sapiens hace cincuenta y cuatro mil
años significa que la llegada de los
humanos modernos de europa está más
compleja de lo que se pensaba